non non soir très heureux que vous ayez
choisi ça s'en va et ça revient pour
parler de votre livre qui est très
bouleversant comme je le dis en
commençant cette émission alors c'est la
première télé que vous faites pour votre
livre est ce que vous êtes plus ou moins
ému que le jour vous êtes entrée dans le
loft c'est différent là parce que
j'entre dans l'oeuf par un jeu là
maintenant je me présente à vous en
ayant fait quelque chose c'est vrai j'ai
dit ici loana ce que je pensais de love
story on a même fait un petit loft
souris avec des souris le loft ou et
passa très dangereuse que je trouve
dangereux c'est ce que ça peut amener
derrière comme comme type des missions
dangereuses
aujourd'hui on n'est pas ici pour parler
que du loft on est là pour parler de
vous alors la question tout le monde va
vous la pose et il va falloir vous
habituer à la répondre pourquoi miettes
donc il ya une anecdote qui est toute
prête cervelle à moi pour la première
fois parce qu'en fait c'est le surnom
que me donne ma mère depuis que suis
tout petit tout petit donc à une puce
pour sa part ya tous les surnoms je
pense qu'on a tous de par notre mère et
c'est vrai que ma mère pages tout en
miettes même mène encore un est vrai que
vous allez en tout rouge aux alentours
des 7 ans on a toujours cette curiosité
tout le temps de dire pourquoi si
pourquoi ça et donc un jour j'allais
voir d'un mois j'ai fait pas vraiment
pourquoi tu m'appelles miettes et donc
ma mère en fait elle m'a répondu du tac
au tac et m'a dit pour moi la famille
c'est comme un pain donc ton père c'est
la croûte dure protectrice moi je suis
l'ami douce tendre et donc un petit bout
de en fait ça fait ligne est voilà alors
lui demander plus parce qu elle vous
racontera exactement la même chose et
chaque fois alors à saint tropez tout le
monde croyait voici votre temps et
boîtes de nuit ou à la plage en fait
vous écriviez moyen de temps par jour
c'est entre 2 et 5 heures c'est beaucoup
quand même
alors celui vous l'avez fait pour faire
un certain nombre de mises au point
d'abord par rapport à votre enfant dont
on a beaucoup parlé
ensuite par rapport aux médias parce que
beaucoup de choses fausses ont été
racontées sur vous beaucoup de choses
inventées
c'est aussi une mise au point sur votre
vie amoureuse ce bouquin parce que c'est
vrai qu'on vous a vu tomber assez
facilement dans les bras de jean edouard
il vous raconter dans ce livre que vous
n'avez jamais eu aussi mal dans votre
vie ce qui est pas terrible un sofa je
sais pas si c'est un livre pour vous
reconstruire vous dites faire mon livre
c'est refaire ma vie
oui un peu ouais disons qu'en fait ce
livre enfin le loft story en fait ça et
ça a été une clôture séparation entre la
vie d'avant la vie de maintenant vous
que je pense que je suis à même de pour
écrire un livre parce que maintenant ma
vie est tellement différente
ça va être autre chose ça change mais
j'ai fait aussi un peu moi ça a été un
peu une sorte de thérapie parce que
c'est vrai que toutes les choses qui
sont écrites à l'intérieur j'ai voulu
les enfouir à l'intérieur de moi et je
pense pas que c'est vraiment la bonne
chose à faire quand on a un souci n
importe quoi il faut en parler
et là on se rend compte que les gens qui
sont autour de soi des fois on les mêmes
soucis que nous c'est vrai que j'ai du
mal à l'exprimer donc je me suis dit
faire un livre en fête a été un peu ma
thérapie j'ai pu marquer sur sur papier
toutes mes émotions
les gens vont le lire vont l'aimer ne
pas l'aimer je sais pas mais pour moi ça
a été un soulagement valence et je mets
à part
ben c'est un livre qui parle de l'autre
loana
alors on va voir au revoir que votre
histoire c'est un peu marilyn mais c'est
d'abord cendrillon parce que quand vous
arrivez au loft vous dit j'avais perdu
toute ambition
je me voyais pour des années dans la
même situation une poupée dansant sur
des podiums je stagnais cette gto un peu
au bout du rouleau quand vous êtes
arrivé dans le travail qui me plaisait
mais je voyais pas l'avenir favoriser le
pas vraiment énormément parce que fait
de se montrer en fait on voit que notre
corps est pas vraiment notre
intelligence c'est vrai que c'est pas
très valorisant mais je ne savais pas
comment serge havet pas c'est vrai
j'avais pas fait beaucoup d'études
il fallait que je travaille pour gagner
de l'argent pour vivre et c'est vrai que
je voyais pas d'avenir je me disais
j'aimerais être mannequin mais j'avais
frappé déjà quelques portes
elle était restée fermée en fait et donc
je voyais pas d'avenir oncle est vrai
que j'ai à travailler c'était en fait
une sorte de routine
j'avais plus trop d'ambition plus trop
d'avenir aujourd'hui quand vous vous
décrivez vous dit je suis la gagnante du
loft
enfin vous n'avez même pas besoin de le
dire puisque toute la france le sait à
ce moment là c'était difficile parce que
quand vous remplissez les formulaires
pour vous inscrire à loft story
quand on vous demande de vous décrire
vous écrivez introverti enfin vous avez
du mal à vous d'écrire à ce moment là
c'est sûr que quand j'ai vu la question
j'ai un peu vu ces faits mais qu'est ce
que je pourrais marquer je peux pas
marquer quelque chose qui me ressemble
pas et c'est très dur de se décrire
alors j'ai marqué c'est de marquer
quelques côté positif c'est un proverbe
alors j'ai paris quelques côtés positifs
généreuse bienveillante envers envers
les personnes que j'aime et c'est vrai
que j'ai marqué les côtés un peu négatif
introverti un petit nul alors vous
raconter comment vous avez été choisi
pour être lofteuse 8000 dossiers 500
candidatures retenues et le casting car
le casting c'est terrible parce que
quand vous arrivez le mec qui vous caste
benoît vous dis t'as pas honte d'être
habillée comme ça alors vous prenez ça
très très mal
oui c'est pris ça très mal si je suis là
bas mais pas très sûr de moi en fait
c'était un petit peu inquiète est vrai
que quand on arrive en s'asseoir et la
personne qui en face me dit mais tu es
vraiment mal fringuée jeu
mfff étape avant de devenir comme ça
mais en fait j'ai posé la question à
tout le monde en fait c'était une
station au texas elle disait et posé la
question à tout le monde mais vous ne
saviez pas à ce moment là alors après
vous demande de draguer la caméra non
moi j'ai dit c'est impossible déjà dans
la dans la vie j'y arrive pas donc j'ai
un très difficilement je suis très ténue
donc je commence à rougir du végal c'est
très dur donc j'ai dit non je trouve pas
donc l'a bien fait pendant cinq minutes
quand ma main je suis pas arrivé après
c'est vrai qu'il m'a dit bon ballon
danse j'ai fait je vais pas danser la
bonne musique qui m'a dit chantier un pc
et une mauvaise mehdi marche sur les
mains en fait et j'ai fait je sais pas
le faire mais c'est vrai quand je suis
sorti de là dedans j'ai fait mince ni
rien j'ai rien montré ça qu'il aura plus
j'en suis sûr alors après donc après il
ya tous les tests psychologiques que 100
intellectuels etc
j'ai 140 d'ailleurs alors après cette
enveloppe est il ya une caméra dans les
toilettes et vous dit on est tous très
émus
on est tous restés quatre jours sans
aller aux toilettes oui c'est vrai mais
vous disais qu'elle marchait pas mais
vous en savez rien mais bon il ya quand
même caméra je suis né dans une caméra
un micro derrière et c'est vrai que tous
tous tous pendant quatre jours il n'y
est pas allé
stevie la première fois qu'il vous voyez
vous dis toi tu t'es fait refaire les
seins alors vous savez pas quoi répondre
vous dites quand même c'est un peu
emmerdant
il est ici je dis non ils vont tous
mater quand je vais prendre ma douche
dont vous décidez de dire oui oui c'est
une question à laquelle je répondais non
forcément quand on est à l'extérieur
parce que bon ça regarde personne si
j'avais fait ça c'était c'est pour moi
et donc c'est vrai que dans les
conversions normal je mettais pas enfin
j'essaie tant que l'enjeu était très
vite et c'est vrai que là la situation
était différente style il m'a posé la
question j'ai réfléchi en deux manches
je me suis dit je suis rentré là c'est
pour être moi même j'ai c'est d'être
franche aux tests et tout et puis bon il
ya des caméras tout le monde nous voit
je me serais pas la peine commencé à
mentir c'est vrai que j'ai dit oui et
c'est vrai qu'au bout de deux minutes je
suis parti quand même dans la chambre et
j'ai enfilé un coup de fil pour éviter
comme voici tout est question disent
yeux braqués sur vous instantanément
mais alors le 18 mai à 14 heures le
monde s'écroule vous êtes convoqué
justement au confessionnal et la voix
vous dis loana dans la presse il est
paru que tu as une petite fille qui
s'appelle mindy et c'est vrai quand vous
aviez rempli le questionnaire on vous
demandez est-ce que vous avez un enfant
à charge vous ai dit non parce qu'en
fait c'est vrai l'enfant n'était pas
vraiment à charge puisque un enfant à
charge c'est si vous l'aviez quitter si
vous l'aviez laissée à la maison tu es
sépare alors une mère de son enfant et
pouvoir qu'elle enfin qu'elle ne voyais
pas avec l'enfant ne voyais pas ça
maintenant
pendant tant de moi c'est vrai que moi
je l'avais pas avec moi tous les jours
mais j'ai beaucoup hésiter sur la
réponse à la question quand même alors
là quand la voix vous dit ça d'un seul
coup c'est plus un jeu quoi
ça le monde s'écroule c'est à dire d'un
seul c'est vrai je te bord de la piscine
dont j'étais là tranquille on m'a appelé
dans le confessionnal on m'a annoncé çà
et là d'un seul coup j'ai eu plein de
questions qui me sont passés à travers
la tête ça a été
déjà mal j'ai pensé à ma mère j'ai pensé
à tous mes amis en fait qui ne le
savaient pas une bonne partie j'ai pensé
en fait à tout le monde tous les gens
qui nous regardent vers la caméra je me
dis comment est-ce qu'ils vont le
prendre à ce que je veux pas être juger
trop sévèrement quand je vais sortir
est-ce qu'on va pas me lui et j'ai eu
vraiment très très grosse angoisse et
c'est vrai qu'on m'a posé la question
est ce que tu veux sortir
ouais et j'ai répondu surtout pas oui
parce que bizarrement vous vous sentez
protéger on est certes un mariage alors
que les des caméras partout la france
entière vous regardez vous sentez quand
même dans une certaine intimité dans
l'oeuf
vous préférez rester que sortir swing
j'ai préféré parce que déjà les
questions qui me posait pas déjà la
production les qualifications que m'ont
posée en fait ça dessus déclencher des
larmes et je me suis dit en sortant en
fait il ya tous les journalistes ont
posé des questions encore plus dur et
j'avais envie de respirer encore un peut
être voir sortir j'avais su que la photo
était paru en une de paris match
non c'est non on attend j'avais pas on
n'avait pas des détails moi j'essaye
d'état j'ai juste eu cette phrase là
ouais ouais on ne savait pas dans quel
jeu cette réduction qui avait demandé à
votre mère de la donner pour couper
court aux rumeurs mais ça vous le saviez
pas c'était pas ça c'était ma tante qui
avait fait qu'ils avaient fait une
interview en fait ce qui avait raconté
l'histoire de ma fille trait faussement
d'ailleurs pour qu'elle avait raconté
des choses riz qu'ils ont désormais dix
ans de la part de votre temps qui disent
on a voulu l'adopter alors qu'ils vous
ont chaise c'est qu'ils m'ont chassée de
chez eux et n'ont jamais demandé si
j'avais 100 francs pour manger vrai du
tout passé comme ça alors là tout vous
revient bien entendu dans le bouquin on
d'un seul coup on passe dans votre dans
votre vie et c'est vrai que si vous avez
été jugé sévèrement sur le moment
peut-être en tous les cas quand on lit
l'histoire on vous juge plus du tout
sévèrement donc l'histoire de la voilà
donc vous vivez avec gwenaëlle quitte
votre vrai grand amour en tous les cas
c'était le premier vous avec lui depuis
six ans et puis un jour il part dans le
nord travaillé pour deux mois
et vous pendant qu'il est pas là vous
rencontrez un mot de garçons vous tomber
enceinte
au début vous ne prêtez pas attention je
ne dis pas que je n'ai pas prêté
attention en fait c'est je m'en suis
aperçu quand j'étais enceinte de quatre
mois
parce qu'en fait je continue à voir mes
règles normalement mais j'avais pas
j'avais pas devin trop fait j'ai
commencé à avoir du vent à partir de six
mois sept mois parce que j'étais très
musclé beaucoup d'ados qui s'est en fait
les ados tiers pas et
le centre reste assez plat donc c'est
vrai j'avais pris quelques kilos j'avais
un peu laissé un peu gonflé de la manche
aller voir mon gynécologue et voilà j'ai
eu quelques petits trucs un peu bizarres
mais j'avais pas de vomissements rien du
tout moi je suis en forme je danse
rapport sur des podiums et donc on a
fait une prise de sang et il m'a dit tu
es enceinte de cana est là le problème
c'est qu'on peut plus faire avorter en
france il faut aller à l'étranger pour
se faire avorter vous trouver l'argent
vous prenez un avion pour la madrid
et là où c'est très touchant c'est que
avant le départ vous fait une
échographie la première échographie pour
savoir si si c'est bien formés ouais
vous la voyez pas ma fille pour la
première voilà dans la lumière bleue de
l'échographie comme ça et là à l'arrivée
à madrid vous n'arrivez pas à vous faire
avorter en fait non parce que c'est vrai
que j'avais un petit peu l'image qui me
vanter je crois que c'est
psychologiquement je pense que je
commençais déjà à la sentir et
c'est vrai que je suis arrivé dans cette
ville c'est vrai j'ai marché tout
l'après midi
et c'est vrai que je suis rentré le soir
s'en passer donc tous ceux qui vous ont
jugé sévèrement finalement s'apercevront
en lisant votre livre que finalement
vous avez refusé de vous faire avorter
que j'ai préféré garder cet enfant alors
au début vous dit je vais me débrouiller
en fait vous n'êtes pas arrivé c'est
l'espoir je pense là ce partage et je me
suis dit c'est bon je vais trouver un
appartement je vais trouver un autre
travail est en fait les mois sont passés
très vite et j'ai pas trouvé
j'étais encore avec mon premier amour
mais l'enfant n'était pas de lui et ma
mère à ce moment là était un petit peu
en dépression nerveuse en fait je me
suis retrouvée seule avec lui dans sa
famille avec cet enfant qui n'était pas
le enfin de leur sang donc tant que
j'avais pas beaucoup de choix
c'était oui peut-être que j'aurais pu
trouver un petit appartement un petit
peu miteux où je fais pas trouvé un
n'importe quel boulot mais ce n'est pas
l'avis que j'aurais voulu pour ma fille
tu aurais vu qu'elle grandisse avec un
père une mère des gens qu'il aime avec
un beau foyer et c'est vrai que c'était
très dur de prendre cette décision là
alors là vous êtes partagés parce qu'à
la fois vous voulez garder cet enfant
vous l'avez prouvé en rentrant de madrid
sans vous faire avorter et en même temps
ben oui vous mettez des bandes sur le
ventre parce que voilà vous voulez
continuer à la famille mais pas mort et
j'attends enfin savoir c'est vrai que je
mettais des banques y compris c'est le
ventre
et c'est vrai que j'essaie de faire tout
comme tout comme une fille normale donc
j'allais faire des cours je sortais mon
chien j'essaie de rester actif
c'est vrai que quand je rentrais dans la
chambre qui avait plus personne qui me
voyaient c'est vrai je m'écroulais sur
le nom et vous étiez même arrivé de me
mettre des coups de poing sur levante de
rage quoi pour la perdre ouais ça
m'arrivait aussi quelquefois dans ma
douche des fois je ne sais c'est pas
possible
j'en ai je vais jamais y arriver
et c'est vrai qu'il m'est arrivé d'avoir
ce geste malheureux quelquefois au
problème avec gwenaëlle évidemment
puisque l'enfant n'est pas de lui et
qu'il a été fait pendant une absence
accouchement extrêmement difficile sans
péridurale pourquoi parce que j'ai en
fait il avait touché un mois plus tôt
parce que j'avais des complications du
fait que je serai beaucoup mon ventre et
donc je rentrais à l'hôpital on m'a fait
à l'accouchement fait accélérer donc des
piqûres à partir de 6 heures du matin
pour voir ce que ça soit provoquer et à
19 heures jeux et enfin j'avais toujours
des contractions mais avait rien ils
avaient peur que je passe la nuit comme
ça dans ce qu'ils ont fait c'est qu'en
fait ils sont ok ils ont provoqué il en
fait ils ont crevé la poche d'eau ce qui
fait que ça accélère l'accouchement et
au moment où j'allais pour accoucher on
enfin où j'aurais dû avoir la péridurale
il y avait deux médecins qui était en
train de avec d'autres femmes qui
accouchent et est donc moi y avait pas
de médecin pour moi et au moment où faty
lynx libéré c'est trop tard je met la
vie du bébé en danger ça fait que vous
ayez déjà couché à l'ancienne et puis à
l'ancienne et puis avec beaucoup de
problèmes 22 points de l'épisiotomie ça
s'est déchiré alors pendant ces deux
jours vous êtes maman oui vraiment maman
et puis un jour vous dites à
l'assistante sociale je vais pas pouvoir
m'en occuper il ya deux infirmières qui
rentre dans la chambre et qu'il parte
avec l'enfant et là vous l'entendez
pleurer pour la première fois c'est à
dire que pendant les sept jours où elle
est restée avec vous elle n'a pas pleuré
du tout c'était un bébé extraordinaire
c'est l'été je sais pas si c'est parce
que tu es maman pour la première fois
alors on s'inquiète toujours et c'est
vrai qu'elle ne pleurait pas allaiter de
tressage et souvent la nuit je la
prenais pour dormir l'endormir contre
moi et c'est vrai qu'elle n'avait jamais
pleuré c'est vrai que quand on me l'a
enlevé
elle était à plusieurs salles plus loin
mais je l'entends faire reconnaissant
avoir où l'entendait et c'est vrai qu'à
la plus riche tournoi où je suis parti
je sais qu'elle a pu répondre autant
elle refuse de se nourrir à l'affection
appel parce qu'on appelle c'est assez
rare mais l'anorexie d'une nourrice oui
c'est vrai j'ai appris ça beaucoup plus
tard quand j'ai décidé de la revoir
et on m'avait appris qu'elle a eue
pendant le premier mois elle refusait de
se nourrir totalement elle voulait pas
donc elle a commencé à dépérir un petit
peu après avec la médecine actuelle on a
bien sûr réussir à la gare nourrir mais
c'est vrai que ça a été très dur les
premiers temps dès que j'ai laissé alors
que c'était un bébé goinfre ça elle
mangeait plus que environ et les
infirmières donc de lait tout le temps
parce que j'ai toujours dû en donner
parce que c'est elle pleure elle peut
aller en qu'enfin bon on est toujours
comme ça je pense mais maman et c'est
vrai que vous engueuler souvent et sur
laquelle elle refusait de se nourrir
alors vous la faites pas adopter un vous
la placez d'abord puis ensuite dans une
pouponnière où vous allez la voir en
cachette
deux fois par semaine et puis un jour
vous réalisez que vous la recupèrerait
jamais vous allez voir mindy dans votre
fille dans sa famille d'accueil
et puis un jour elle vous repousse parce
que c'est pas vous qui avez l'habitude
de lui donner à manger donc quand vous
approchez df vous repousse parce qu'elle
elle a pris l'habitude que ce soit sa
maman d'adoption qui lui donne à manger
ça vous avait flingué quoi ça m'a fait
énormément match on a pleuré pendant
deux jours parce que j'ai essayé de
faire du mieux que je pouvais ça c'était
très pénible hop on a déjà de lavaur et
de pouvoir en fait la laisser mais c'est
vrai quand elle a eu ce geste un petit
peu c'est vrai que ça m'a énormément
fait maastricht
en fait j'ai posé les affaires c'est
vrai que suis parti en courant et c'est
là sa maman un petit peu d'adoptions sa
tata qui est venu et m'a dit mais c'est
normal c'est pas grave
et c'est vrai que moi j'étais en larmes
et je comprenais pas trop bien c'est pas
vous qui la nourrit si habituellement
pour ça et vous dit l'avoir me faisait
plus de mal que de bien
quand vous y alliez était heureuse et
quand vous repartiez vous étiez effondré
quand on me l'avait enlevée quand même
les prises à l'hôpital
c'est vrai que c'est très dur de laisser
alors j'étais pas retourner la voir
depuis la fin du loft pourquoi parce que
j'ai tout simplement j'ai vu un petit
peu la presse je prends des nouvelles je
sais qu'elle va très bien mais j'ai peur
qu'en fait on allant la voir j'ai pas
envie que n'importe quel paradis me
suivent
d'après dans photo et ensuite enfin et
des photos de loi n'a dans certains
endroits et j'ai paniqué plein de monde
qui viennent la voir je vois qu'elle
grandisse normalement pas ce que j'ai
fait j'ai pas vu le faire contre elle
j'ai pas envie de te manquer autant de
tâches qui autour d'elle
qu'il ya autour de moi donc voila quand
on lit votre bouquin des gens on apprend
cette histoire et puis après on découvre
votre enfance votre père donc été
magasinier jusqu'à ce qu' il perdre son
travail vous dit quand il a perdu son
travail l'a perdu sa fierté
il pouvait plus assumer son foyer et là
il a commencé un peu à devenir un
picoler un peu à devenir un peu
colérique quoi je pense que oui c'était
c'est une famille un petit peu d'italien
et un petit peu la famille d'avancé vrai
que le père quand il perd son travail on
a un travail et par il perd un peu le
statut de chef des chefs gens du milieu
ils sont un petit peu diminué je pense
que ça qui l'a pas supporté son enfance
à lui n'était pas très facile non plus
la nuit il était clair oui voyez
toujours son père à lui qui battait sa
mère wii est un jeu initiale terrible
dans votre bouquin c'est qui celui se
révèle votre père donc ils se révoltent
contre son propre père qui battait sa
mère et sa mère dans votre grand-mère au
lieu de au lieu de l'aider lui elle lui
tient les poignées pendant que son père
le bas c'est à dire qu'à ce moment là la
femme du foyer était passé du côté de
l'homme qui a passé la greffe amiral
yann malet le père te faire ce qu'il
veut on n'a pas le droit au toucher au
père de famille ça veut dire que même si
le père bas
sa femme elle ne se rebelle pas contre
elle pense que c'est bien donc le fait
que mon père ait eu ce geste là elle n'a
pas accepté mais mon père ne l'a pas que
c'était lui non plus parce que lui c'est
ça pour l'aider alors votre père il est
tellement malheureux d'avoir perdu son
boulot il est tellement dépressif de ça
qu'il commence à battre votre merde à
fait vrai qu'il eut donné des gifles
c'est souvent des injures donc un peu un
rabaissement peu d humiliation mais ce
n'était pas à la barre
elle pouvait sortir lendemain dans la
rue sans forcément tout le monde se
rende compte vous dans ces cas là vous
allez vous réfugier sous une chaise
c'est vrai que quelquefois les choses
que j'avais s'est réfugié sous la chaise
de ma mère ce que j'avais l'impression
qu'elle me protégeait un peu et c'est
vrai que je restais là un peu bloquée
alors un jour il ya une scène très
fortes à dire que votre père était
chasseur il adorait chasse et votre mère
constatations bodmer prend un fusil
elle ne vise lui se retourne il s'en
aperçoit et il attrape le fusil comme ça
et là qu'est ce qui s'est passé est le
cas ce parterre et le casse de rage par
terre il s'en va et votre mère s'en va
et c'est à ce moment là qu en fait ma
mère est partie elle a fait elle a pris
quelques affaires elle a pris la voiture
j'ai effectué par où elle m'a dit tu
t'inquiètes pas je reviendrai
ouais c'est vrai qu'elle est partie
c'est vrai qu'elle est revenue à l'est
alors là sa colère retombe sur vous il
boit et puis vous vous restez tout seul
avec lui et puis alors il est il est
quand même méchant avec vous parce que
quand ils vous êtes en sixième à cette
époque là donc c'est très jeune quand
ils vous emmènent en voiture en sixième
il vous dit tu seras une [ __ ] comme ta
mère ce que de bord est pas vrai et
deuxièmement et d'une méchanceté totale
quand même non respectée soit malheureux
pour être méchant comme ça non je pense
qu'il était très malheureux je pense je
ne sais pas s'il avait bien réalisé
pourquoi est ce que ma mère était partie
je pense qu'il a dû penser qu'il était
parti comme ça sans aucune raison alors
qu'elle en avait et c'est vrai que c'est
reporté un peu sur moi je ressemble à ma
mère j'étais la seule fille qui était là
il fallait qu'ils montrent sa peine
quand on veut montrer son chagrin on le
monde parle de la part de la méchanceté
et c'est ce qu'il a fait pour moi oui
alors il vous torturent mentalement pas
mais enfin il vous fait jouer parce que
quand tu as journal télévisé il vous
demande de lui raconter les pays comme
l'estonie alexa sur les capitales savait
rien passé les pieds alors il faut
débarrasser la table enfin pas
débarrassé d'ailleurs parce que si vous
dites débarrasser c'est une gigue
desservir la table en dix minutes le
temps qu'il aille promener le chien et
vous dit une phrase terrible qui est
très juste vous dites les gamins en
cette force de ne pas mesurer leur
malheur c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'ils
sont pas compte des fois les enfants
pensent que c'est normal vu qu'en fait
il va et que leurs propres parents
qu'ils soient les parents des autres
donc ils pensent que leur vie tels qui
la visaient les normales pour alors pour
moi elle était pas à l était pas de
mauvaises jeu c'est vrai que je
souffrais un petit peu le soir mais
c'est vrai que l'après midi j'étais une
fille comme toutes les autres
je m'amuse et comme toutes les autres
parce que je pensais que les autres
vivaient la même chose que moi
vous en parlez pas à toute façon j'en
parlais pas alors il va très loin parce
qu'un jour présente vous dormait sur un
canapé où je puis vous êtes allés
déjeuner si ma tante 1
il vous réveille en sursaut et il vous
dit que tu seras content tu seras grande
en fait il m'a posé cette question c'est
une question qui revenait inlassablement
ce la question qui me posait quand
j'allais à l'école alors revoir donc
mois par lassitude parce que je venais
de me réveiller tout simplement pour lui
faire plaisir j'ai fait je serais qu'une
[ __ ]
oui et c'est vrai que là sa réaction
était très violente qui m'a frappé et en
fait il aurait voulu je réponds d'autres
choses mais moi j'en savais rien vous
avez pu nouvelles de lui aujourd'hui
non j'ai plus de nouvelles de lui vous
allez l'appeler là non je pense pas et
je pense que l'on ne fera pas non plus
je ne sais pas jusqu'à combien de temps
on va tenir
je pense que c'est de la fierté
peut-être un peu malgré ces mais je
crois que c'est héréditaire et c'est
souvent parce que oui voilà donc je
pense que c'est souvent dans ces
familles quand il arrive des très gros
problème peut-être que arrivera
peut-être un jour un drame mais cela
peut-être qu'on se reverra et peut-être
que les liens se ressoude rond mais bien
sûr que j'ai envie de revoir mon père
j'aimerais qu'ils me prennent enfin qui
me disent juste je suis fier de ce que
tu as fait et je veux ça compte roma
mène encore si nous regarde
alors votre maire vient vous voir un
soir elle débarque là dans la maison
vous repartez avec elle il est il la
frappe aussi ce soir là un traumatisme
crânien elle a le nez cassé et la sombre
dans la dépression et ça aussi donc il
est produit problème avec votre père
donc qui lui était assez violent et
votre mère au contraire lui elle devient
dépressive et elle vous renvoie chez lui
alors on va chez moi en fait je crois
que ça un an un an et demi plus tard je
pense qu'elle craquait elle aussi parce
que le fait de partir de reconstruire sa
vie ses nerfs ont lâché je pense que
c'est pendant trop d'années sénart ont
tenu et c'est vrai qu'elle a eu cette
phrase un petit peu malheureuse où j'ai
fait mais tu sais très bien que nous pas
que papa va me frapper
elle m'a répondu oui mais ça fera du
bien ouais y el mar envahi mon cas là
quand vous arrivez chez votre père à
nouveau ça va un peu mieux
oui parce qu'ils étaient avec une fille
qui a pratiquement votre âge oui il a
retrouvé du travail puis
vous avez quoi 16 ans il était avec une
fille de sattel sandrine quelquefois une
vingtaine d'années il vous dit
t'inquiète pas loana j'ai changé donc
vous vous y croyez vous revenez c'est
assez sympa mais quand sandrine amène
son petit garçon parce qu'elle avait un
petit garçon avec un autre homme avant
là il commence à piquer des colères
noires contre le moment je pense pas que
c'était vraiment content le môme je
pense que au début il a été bien puis de
voir peut-être une famille ça l'est
peut-être à pied la nôtre et c'est vrai
qu'il a recommencé à boire et c'est vrai
que ces gestes ont été ont été les mêmes
que précédemment
alors là c'est à tour de rôle avec
sandrine et vous donc à tour de rôle
après le dîner y en a une qui part dans
la chambre avec le boss et il y en a une
qui reste avec votre perte oui et celles
qui restent on en prend plein la gueule
et puis il y en a certains soirs vous
dit elle pourrait quand même venir
s'occuper de son monde mais elle vient
pas et vous y allez pas non plus quand
c'est elle que là bas
oui c'est vrai que j'avais un peu cette
phrase malheureuse quand c'est moi qui
vais rester à table de dire elle
pourrait venir m'aider elle ne faisait
pas mais c'est vrai que quand c'était
mon tour de rester dans la chambre et
dormir un peu c'est vrai que moi non
plus je me déplaçais pas pu en profiter
de cette nuit un petit peu de calme donc
c'est un petit peu égoïste c'était un
soir sur deux un soir de cannes qui
s'était pas tout on savait pas vraiment
tous les soirs mais c'est vrai que ça
devait arriver six fois sur dix
ouais donc oui alors un jour il la
frappe sandrine de votre père et là il
se passe ce qui s'était passé dans son
enfance ir que vous vous lui tenir tête
non mais c'est la première fois que j'ai
tenu tête c'est la seule fois de ma vie
j'ai tenu bon en fait c'est vrai qu'il a
attrapé très très fort et
elle criait vraiment énormément et jusqu
en fait ça m'a réveillé et je me suis
non c'est pas grave rendors toi et il
m'arrive est une espèce de rage une
boule au ventre je me suis dit je devais
avoir 16 ans donc j'étais plus petit je
me suis dit c'est pas normal il faut
qu'il arrête
il va lui arriver là tu fais pas ce que
je fais penser et je me suis levé et
j'ai voulu mettre un peu au milieu des
deux c'est vrai qu'il m'a dit ça te
regarde pas je crois que je suis
retournée dans la chambre elle a recréé
c'est vrai que je me suis levé en fait
de rage les fauchés frappé mon père
ouais là il vous regarde avec un regard
dessous presque oui en fait ils tombent
au sol et en fait il me demande juste un
petit pourquoi pourquoi est ce que tu as
fait sam avec une voix douce et sa main
sur le coup je me suis je n'aurais
jamais dû faire ça j'ai eu de la peine
je voulais c'est dé l'aider à le relever
j'avais les larmes aux yeux
moi ils avaient larmes aux yeux et je
disais ah pardon pardon va pas et en
fait si ces relevés et là il m'a regardé
vraiment méchamment et serge klein m'a
vraiment frappé très fort et vous partez
je m'en voudrais jusqu'aux intérieurs en
chemise de nuit on va descendre et
j'avais vraiment parfois les mains comme
ça collait sur le sol guidon du scooter
et là bon vous retrouvez votre mère
assez amorphe en pleine dépression très
absente comme vous dites mortes de
l'intérieur ouais ouais parce qu'elle
avait une surdose de médicaments c'est
là qu'en fait le toubib lui avait donné
trop de calmants donc complètement
ailleurs
et quand ils ont arrêté quand ils s'en
sont aperçus il a quand même fallu
qu'elle aille en psychiatrie parce
qu'elle avait beaucoup ce qui est un
toxique est passé par ses calmants et
alors là toutes les deux c'est assez
courageux vous commencez à vous dire bon
alors il faut qu on sait qu à ce jeu il
faut qu'on y aille
alors vous prenez toutes les deux un
petit un petit studio comme ça qu'un
s'emballe dans le vieil antibes et puis
après ça commence et les appartements au
premier étage à 2200 âmes
et ça 3003 donc vous commencez à
épargner vous vous serrer les coudes
quoi oui c'est pour ça que c'est aussi
lié avec votre mère maintenant c'est
parfait oui oui bon conseil j'ai bien
galéré ensemble quoi jeu quand on a pris
beaucoup gagné enfants alors un jour il
ya une scène terrible j'ai essayé de
réconcilier vos parents dont vous dites
à votre mère écoute voilà il va venir
pas vraiment pour les réconcilier mais
ça me ferait plaisir les voir enfin
malgré ce qui s'était passé on a
toujours le souhaite de retrouver un
petit peu ça fait vieux et j'étais fier
en fait juste mon père c'était on venait
d'avoir l'appartement à vallauris et mon
nouvel appartement jusqu'à maintenant je
pense et j'étais très fier en fait
d'inviter mon père juste pour dire voilà
regarde où on vit on y arrive et c'est
vrai que donc j'avais dit amer surtout
soit là parce que moi je sais que
j'allais avoir un petit délai de retard
et ses compères n'aime pas le retard et
c'est vrai que ma mère n'était pas là
elle est en train de faire des courses
et je pense que ça l'amusé ne pas être
là ça m'avait beaucoup au fait de la
peine fait ça m'avait beaucoup vexé
c'est pas votre temps danny qu'il ya des
influences c'est le sens qu'il sait
maintenant qu'il avait influencé en lui
disant non niçois passait pas grave
votre mère avait un sourire bizarre
[ __ ] quand vous la retrouvez dryades
rigole franchement alors quoi
pour moi en fait je m'énerve vraiment
jeu mais pourquoi pourquoi tu fais ça je
comptais sur toi tu m'avais promis et
c'est vrai que ma mère rigole est ce moi
je alors sans doute bon évidemment pas
bien mentalement psychique non sans
doute elle disparaît sans laisser d
adresse à les partis sans les de cette
adresse et oui donc ma mère pas enfin je
rentre un soir l'appartement et elle est
pas là bon alors on pas la première soir
je me dis c'est pas grave allait sortir
deuxième soir troisième soirée toujours
pas de nouvelles des fondations travail
il me la passe pas et je ne sais pas où
aller et ça dure comme ça une semaine et
au bout d'un moment fait les factures
arrivent et je le dis comment je vais
faire en fait j'étais en seconde où
j'avais redoubler et jallet fait je
faisais mes études et je faisais mais
comment je vais payer tout ça c'est
également elle qui m'a un peu aidé ouais
et là je tombe je trouve gravement
malade et je pars à l'hôpital où il a
aussi très mal soignée faut dire on voit
quand même parce que finalement on vous
dit vous avez une angine blanche qui
ouvre un jour vous avez des flics m'ont
est tellement infectés que vous avez une
septicémie se frôlent juste la
septicémie set j'étais à deux jours près
des crimes étaient obligés de vous
ouvrir les phlegmons comme ça
brutalement d'avis ils sont énormes que
j'avais
je devais avoir 7 de tensions ils
pouvaient pas m'opérer qu'en fait juste
de l'anesthésié c'est vrai qu'on m'ouvre
est à vif la gorge pour que ça en fait
le sang coule et gwenaëlle est génial
parce qu'il vous faut combien de mots il
vous met devant la télé ils vous porte
dans le lit enfin il a une espèce de
compassion pour vous extraordinaire
c'est très beau ça voilà alors après ben
en sortie d'hôpital vous avez dit chez
les parents de banane on n'avait pas
d'argent donc je tombe je retourne
habiter chez ses parents et là dans la
mer de wana elle yvette dans lequel elle
vit de la chambre de sa fille alexandra
way pour vous installez vous et one avec
la fille avec son bref devant elle et
pas très contente
mais en fait il avait une chambre qui
était beaucoup plus petit et l'action de
bank d'alexandre eyed peas grande et
comme on arrivait à 2 c'est vrai qu'ils
ont interchangé les chants baroques elle
n'était pas contente du tout alors c'est
un ex andra c'est celle qui vous avez
très titre clocharde déjà à votre mère
et vous à l'époque il ne vient pas de
pognon je crois que c'est à l'époque du
studio avec 1 170 la tma c'est ça et
donc elle et elle vous martyrs et
dispose d'une certaine façon si vous
arrivez dans cette famille où tout le
monde est très sympa avec vous et je
dirais surtout yvette vous et quand même
ce problème d'alexandra qui vous en veux
quoi elle est en fait elle faisait tout
contre moi elle raconté à tout le monde
que je couchais à droite et à gauche
donc en fait j'avais une mauvaise
réputation elle prenait mes vêtements
que j'essaie d'acheter avec un petit peu
l'argent que j'avais les déchirer elle
prédit jusqu'à mes sous vêtements pour
les mettre lors de ces règles donc
c'était vraiment elle vraiment été une
méchante et c'est vrai j'en ai beaucoup
souffert
j'en ai bavé comme la marche j'en ai pas
mal moins un jour votre mère vera
réapparaît je ne peux pas vous parler
non tu n'es plus ma fille pourquoi je ne
sais pas vous savez non pas du tout elle
réapparaît en fait elle a disparu
je pense qu'on vient de monter un petit
peu la tête en me disant oui loi d'un
profil de toi ou je sais pas ce qui
s'est passé et c'est vrai qu'elle veut
dit tu n'es plus ma fille là où fait
deux tentatives de suicide quand vous
êtes chez les parents de gwenaëlle à
chaque fois c'est le lavage d'estomac
ouais ouais c'était très dur je pense
que c'est un appel au secours
je voulais vraiment mourir ce moment là
maintenant je réalise 13 ça plutôt comme
un appel au secours auprès des parents
pour leur dire regardez moi faites
quelque chose et ils ont pas bougé
puis vous réfugier dans les animaux
s'ils avouent commencé là dans cette
maison avec ma famille mais en ayant un
peu délaissé j'avais besoin de me sentir
importante pour quelqu'un pour quelque
chose
lionel bien sûr ils étaient là mais
c'était pas pareil donc c'est vrai que
c'est là que j'ai commencé à pêcher des
abymes haut à droite à gauche à les
élever les soigner juste pour me sentir
un baume à dire voilà grâce à moi est
quelque chose qui se passe et c'est pour
ça que j'adore les animaux pis
donc voilà qui est loana c'est pas une
dragueuse une mangeuse d'hommes une vamp
une bimbo s'est pas du tout c'est
quelqu'un même quand vous étiez kogure
enfin que vos danseuse vous avez refusé
pas mal de propositions vénale toujours
un
c'est un petit peu une chose dont je
sois fier c'est vrai que même des fois
où j'ai pas à lui et beaucoup d'argent
1 il m'a proposé quelque fois des
grosses sommes ouais 30 du bal trad
puisqu'une format procès jusqu'à 30000
alors vous gagnez 700 francs par soit
ouais j'ai refusé mais je pense quand je
suis rentré chez moi sur l'âge était
plus fier vous parlez de vos hommes il
n'a pas eu beaucoup c'est vrai 6
iguanes elle bon ben voilà c'est la
première fois que vous faites l'amour
c'est avec lui un vrai passion physique
avec les obèses est partout partout mais
c'était l'apprentissage pour tous les
deux parce que lui n'avait jamais fait
moi non plus est
et en fait on s'est découvert l'un
l'autre et je pense que vous cumulez
première fois et quand c'est aussi beau
cd bon assez ça partout marché partout
bon après il ya le père de mindy votre
enfant donc avec il ya eu cette aventure
très courts pendant que boinet l'été
dans le nord lui vous achetez dès que
vous l'avez expliqué que vous étiez en
chine courageux il ya olivier alors là
c'est bon si l'époque qui était un gogo
dancer c'est l'époque des drag queens
tout ça donc c'est une bande de danseurs
et vous dites il était déguisé en femme
et moi j'étais en train de devenir femme
sur votre côté platform boots et tout ça
un peu comme ça ça vient de là quoi
c'est cette époque
sébastien c'est le tombeur et celui-là
il vous avez vous dit je vais pas je
veux pas je veux pas je veux pas mais
quoi il finit quand même pas vous avoir
et est un jouet vous dit cette phrase
terrible on vous dit j'aimerais qu'on se
sépare un petit peu pour faire le point
c'est une phrase terrible parce que là
on se dit il ya un problème et on sait
très bien que quand on fait le point en
principe cette tournée dans tout ça on
n'a pas besoin de faire le point voilà
il ya julien qui est devenu votre
meilleur ami
au départ vous croyez qu'il est
homosexuel et puis pas du tout
apparemment alors il est jaloux un
épouvantablement jaloux 1 1 il profite
un peu de vous quand même il a fait 1 et
aujourd'hui c'est votre meilleure amie
quand même ya jean edouard alors jean
edouard et tout le monde connaît de
interdit puisque c'était la nuit qu'ils
étaient filmés en caméra infrarouge les
images et les carnets ont été ont
circulé sur internet
mais quand même y avait quelque chose de
vrai pour lui ce n'était pas juste pour
moi oui
n'empêche c'est sa passion une belle
gueule
mais je vais pas c'est différent c'est
vrai que quand on est rentré on savait
pas les personnalités les caractères de
chacun donc je me suis retrouvé en face
d'un petit un petit top en fait un temps
je pense est timide
un petit peu comme moine trop versé
maintenant c'est à moi c'est le
contraire et je me suis dit bon on va
être tous les dons baptisée puis ça va
mieux se passer parce que ça se passait
pas très bien j'avais pas un très bon
rapport avec les autres ne s'est pas
passé comme je l'aurais voulu
et cet été à saint-tropez personne
personne depuis un faut le dire ça parce
que tout le monde s'imagine des truc
épouvantable n ont rien bahia j'attends
et puis je pense pas qu'il faille
chercher ça me rend tout seul alors
quand vous arrivez à saint tropez
évidemment vous arrivé en hélicoptère
ça vous rappelle quand on est homo mais
qu'on est dans les embouteillages et
conditionnent un hélico je passerai par
dessus ça vous arrive vraiment arrivé et
là vous réalisez que c'est la gagnante
de loft story c'est là où justement avec
christophe on en parlait pour 10 et là
vraiment on a de la chance est gagnant
parce que là on voyait vraiment qu on
avait quelque chose de plus un an la
villa de rêve est pas terrible à la télé
vous dit si une télé d'avant guerre
on n'avait même pas on n'avait même pas
la chaîne pour laquelle je travaillais
le micro-ondes vous l'attendez cinq
semaines sur 6 mois vous avez eu la
dernière semaine on n'est pas des choses
luxueux des ges que ça soit propre à un
petit peu bas les outils dont se faire
naturellement donc c'est vrai que moi je
dis il n'y a pas à micro ondes et c'est
vrai qu'on a mis cinq semaines pour
l'avoir pour la voir et bien sûr il ya
les gens évidemment les gens il prend un
peu comme ceux qui vous ont élu le
public
il croit que c'est un peu à leur service
et à dire oui loana est ce que tu peux
me signer sa loana regarde par là vous
appartenez un peu à tout le monde c'est
terrible sur la fin ça devenait plus
sévère que des demandes
il faut que tu fasses ta regarde on a
attendu pendant 16 heures tu devrais
venir
et c'était plus des demandes et ça
commence à faire mal au coeur alors dans
la villa vous lisez la bio de marilyn
c'est vrai qu'il ya plein de points
communs avec vous c'est vrai qu'elle a
été abandonnée quand elle était enfant
c'est vrai que toute sa vie elle a
manqué d'amour et qu'elle a cherché
auprès des hommes et de son public donc
il ya plein de très commun et vous
parlez très bien dans votre bouquin de
la d 2 loana vous dites là petites
huîtres et la grande pin-up aptitudes
qui se referme et puis la grande pin-up
jolie ou dit ya deux semaines dans mon
corps et public a aimé les deux les gens
s'y sont pas trompés d'aidé qui vous ont
vu ils ont compris ça cette dualité
je peins fouet c'est la première fois
que ça m'arrive parce que c'est vrai
qu'on voyait souvent la loana
extravertie
ça crie ça qui donne sur les podiums
parce que l'autre était trop timide pour
pouvoir s'imposer
et je pense que l'intérêt de l'offre ou
convoyer 24 heures/24 je pense que les
gens ont réussi à percer ça et ça donne
d'autant plus confiance en moi comment
je peux me dire que je peux être comme
je veux comme vous êtes vraiment
réconcilier les deux lois naturelles
public vous a laissée dans le loft
jusque là victoire
oui donc c'est bien qu'ils vous aimez il
a une phrase qui est très bien vous
dites j'ai été battu et j'ai dû me
battre comme tous ceux qui ne sont pas
nés du côté ensoleillé de la rue c'est
vrai quand on vit cette histoire on peut
plus vous en vouloir pour rien parce que
c'est une histoire un peu triste une
enfance un peu un peu malheureuse mais
l'idiot testard avoir fait quoi que ce
soit maintenant je dois faire la route à
l'envers dans prenant soin le prouve
effectivement choix que le bouquin il
participe à ce que c'est bien donc ça
déjà ça vous ait fait quelque chose que
vous disiez tout à l'heure en arrivant
vous dit en parlant de votre bouquin ma
vie était pleine de trous et de
révélations avec un fil et une aiguille
pendant l'été gelé recousu oui ça va
mieux
c'est ce que j'étais un petit peu à la
on a tendance trop enfouir a essayé
d'oublier leurs clés en le mettant un
jour je me sers est construit avec moi
même avec mon passé donc ça s'appelle
miettes c'est chez power et c'est signer
loana petrucciani parce que tu allais
votre nom
alors
on va souffler un peu après toutes ces
aventures on va regarder quelques images
on va voir margerie votre ami d'enfance
on va voir yvette la mère de gwenaëlle
qu'on appelait votre seconde maman au
revoir violette votre mère magnéto c'est
dans le midi de la france que loana a
passé ses dix premières années
nous y avons retrouvé margerie une
inséparable ami d'enfance
elles ne se sont pas revus depuis dix
ans peut-être regarder la télé oui c'est
loin de là et lui ni mais qui sont là
bas c'est ma copine au collège et et
j'en suis pas venu le seul à rester
bouche bée j'ai vu mes parents tout de
suite je leur dis regardez qui a la télé
s'éloignera et voilà c'était la grande
pour la première fois yvette la seconde
maman de loana ouvre ses portes à la
télévision
messieurs c'est ici
pour monter des escaliers
oui
bien je vais vous faire visiter un peu
le l'ancien univers de luan alors la
cuisine qui est interdite qui est en
travaux
donc pourtant c'est l univers favori de
l'ona à oui c'est une très grosse
mangeuse très gourmande elle se levait
même la nuit pour manger loinard mon
service et chez moi parce qu'elle avait
beaucoup de problèmes avec et son père
et sa mère
le début je n'étais pas trop d'accord
qu'elle habite ici
elle était mineure elle n'avait que 15
ans et c'est ma fille alexandra qui me
dit mais tu sais maman elle est très
malheureuse elle est dans la rue et
embaucher vie alors elle a commencé deux
jours par semaine à dormir à la maison
et puis après ça a été tout le temps
après quand même maman mais on a
beaucoup de l'infection l'une pour
l'autre
comme elle était très réservé s'il y
avait une personne étrangère à la
famille est le seul aliment loi n'a
assez souvent de petits cadeaux à son
premier petit cadeau c'est le nounours
rose qui est là
ça a été le premier cadeau de loana est
un de ces derniers cadeaux
s
été
ce sit in
[Musique]
l'amitié est un joyau de moqueur il
écrit je vais vous montrer une marque de
loi n'a que nous allons garder
précieusement
voilà luan a aggravé son prénom vente du
béton alors loana 92 gravé par luan a tu
viens jambes allaient rentrer à les
jeunes
les derniers moments d'anonymat c'est
ici à nice que loana les a passées elle
partageait avec sa maman un minuscule
studio si sa maison à la toute petite
maison de loana et de sa maman ici ça
ressemble plutôt à une maison de poupée
mais parce qu'à beaucoup de petits
souvenirs et dans un espace réduit
on met des petites choses et chaque
chose à sa valeur l'année dernière pour
son anniversaire j'ai pas beaucoup de
sous et
et généralement pour votre anniversaire
on essaye de soufre est quelque chose de
qui sort de l'ordinaire qui étonne qui
est un c'est quelque chose que safran
c'est moi qui choisis en couleurs la clé
sur ça lui correspond bien
[Musique]
et différence des autres chance et qu'on
vit on vivaient pas ensemble les mêmes
joueurs et loana en fait dorment le jour
moi je dormais la nuit ça faisait
beaucoup d'heures sur un matelas c'est
quelque chose je le redirai volonté
s'est jeté les saynètes dont tu as fait
princesse tu as été ma petite étoile
tout le long du loft et bien avant et
reste plus qu'à grandir et à vyntra de
venir sonner
elle est où votre maman maintenant la
halle à nice alors repris le travail
mais la recrue travail c'est gwenaëlle
qui vous a réconcilié parce que vous
êtes resté deux ans sans l'avoir
l'époque 1
les retrouvailles ont été assez froide
ouais parce qu'en fait on pensait
qu'elle avait monté un petit peu un
stratagème est prévenu par un boulanger
rencontre est amère mais ce qu'elle va
mal elle voudrait parler là bien quoi il
m'a dit surtout le dis pas que c'est moi
qui te dit tu voudras pas de parler et
la vie inversement à ma mère est en fait
donc on s'est retrouvé à une table d'un
restaurant en train de boire un verre en
pensant que l'une avait besoin de
l'autre alors qu'on était tellement fier
qu'on l'aurait jamais fait nous mêmes
donc on a commencé à se voir une heure
puis une journée puis au fur et à mesure
maintenant est ce la femme la plus
importante de ma vie réelle vous regarde
là ma mère
oui je pense pas du tout elle est là
c
là j'ai failli pleurer avait failli
faire un homme qu'il est émouvant le
bouquin j'ai failli pleurer
alors dites moi parce que dans le
bouquin il ya une question à laquelle
même loana ne peux pas répondre pourquoi
m'en voulait plus la voir
je crois que il ya des choses dans la
vie qui font que c'est plus paix mais
ces sentiments et on sait pas
et puis quand on n'est pas bien
psychologiquement et tout il ya
peut-être des choses quand on dit que
qui sont pas vrais nids et commencer
perron s'est plus exprimé on sait plus
et je pense que c'est à ce niveau là
vous en êtes volutes ça en fait je me
rappelais pas mais pas du tout vous
pourrez re découvert tout à l'heure en
regardant un c'est l'époque vous prenez
beaucoup de calmants je m'en suis aperçu
après mais sur le moment ont
certainement pas ouais je pense pas que
cette époque là qui quand je pense que
ce n'est pas qu'ils aient maintenant oui
mais maintenant ça va très bien parce
que tout à fait ça a été un passage je
crois qu'après des périodes très
difficiles et bien n'importe qui peut
être à même de faire une dépression et
bien s'ils réagissent d'une si vous avez
vécu bien sûr on voit bien d'ailleurs
quand le soir de l'émission de la sortie
du loft c'est vous qu'elle regarde dans
la salle c'est pas benjamin castaldi
moi je crois bien que c'est elle aussi
que je regarde c'est pas bien que
longtemps voilà j'avais pas lu pendant
70 jours et
c'est vrai que j'avais envie de lui
demander j'avais roulé assez fort dans
mes bras il ya tellement de fort en fait
je les appelais mais sans vraiment de
dire enfin bouger c'est une pause de me
poser des questions comment être qu'elle
veut de l'avoir comme ça alors après
tant de jours j'aurais voulu la voir
j'étais captivé du soir dans ma maman ça
va maintenant
ah oui oui ça va bien mieux
mais distrait ça je suis dit que je me
repose et bien c'est vrai tu fais ça va
il fait huit ça va bien je dis tout
montrer la semaine j'ai demandé à
quelqu'un d'autre de venir ce soir c'est
une amie à vous une copine à vous à
l'époque vous étiez adolescente c'est
marjorie
alors vous étiez vous étiez ensemble
c'est quoi à l'époque en troisième dont
césar c'est l'époque où loana
commençaient à montrer de l'intérêt pour
les garçons vous aussi non
entamant sa demande mais c'était un
amusement les regarder de loin et puis
je pense comme ça fait du bien après
quand même sérieusement mais ça parce
que vos parents regardent mans a non non
pas du tout ça ça non mais papa était
comment à l'époque alors est ce qu'elle
vous raconter par exemple ce qui se
passait chez elle les problèmes qu'elle
avait avec son père sa mère qui était
dépressive est ce que tu es un petit peu
et au courant mais c'était pas en détail
c'est vrai qu'on n'en parlait pas
énormément
bon je savais que ça allait pas très
très bien
c'était bon guerre non je pense que
c'est très naturellement non elle ne
montrait pas donner sur elle beaucoup je
trouve elle vous elles veulent se
baigner pas non pas tellement les autres
n'étaient au courant de rien ça c'est
sûr et certain
ouais c'est avec elle c'était des
moments heureux sur des fois il
s'aperçoit que des fois je pleurais un
petit peu donc c'est des questions mais
j'étais vite les ébruiter parce que
j'étais avec elle ces tests et les fous
rires que comptez vous êtes rappelé revu
après le prix de l'offre à depuis le
loft non parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'amis
de loana beaucoup de copines de l'époque
dont vous dit pas du bien dans le
bouquin il a beaucoup qui vous ont trahi
il y en a beaucoup qui ont été noyés
marjorie ça va jamais ça c'est mon
meilleur souvenir bien il ya une autre
personne aussi qui était avec vous
n'avez pas que vous dansiez joël oui
ou non
tout le monde est là c'est génial je
pense que c'était très bien
alors donc à l'époque vous voulez vous
continuer à danser vos souris toujours
sur la côte est oui ouais c'est que
j'étais disent ok whisky à gogo un agent
les pins donc je connais bien c'est pas
d'hier j'ai connu ça aussi vous ai
travaillé au whisky toutes les deux
magnifiques loi n'a plus de boulot
vous avez trouvé une autre partenaire
maintenant non vous arrêtez doucement
alors à l'époque l'ona nous disait qu
effectivement quand on pense comme ça
tout là toute la soirée enfin ces trois
fois vingt minutes incessamment oui il
ya toujours des propositions loana nous
disait qu'elle avait gagné 700 francs
par soir ce n'était pas terrible qui
avait toujours refusé les propositions
vénale vous être vus depuis le pilote
non téléphone mais on ne sait pas pu
aller à bon ben voilà d'après l'édition
voilà ils manquent ils n'ont que
quelqu'un ici ce soir c'est yvette elle
est là
[Musique]
m
formidable yvette heureusement vous avez
été là aussi un la seconde maman comme
on dit à votre fils a été le cas
apparemment d'après ce qui ressort du
bouquin le grand amour de loana il a
fait beaucoup pour elle quand elle était
malade il s'est beaucoup donné de mal je
crois oui et vous vous les avez
accueilli chez vous donc
pourtant il n'y a pas beaucoup de place
non mais on faisait eric ouais vous
allez dire et alexandra deçà champ pour
les installer trop minable c'est
formidable ça moscou et c'est chez vous
qu'elle a fait ses deux tentatives de
suicide deux avaient eu peur oui mais la
première en on l'a su que le lendemain
mon fils l'a transporté seul à l'hôpital
- et on l'a su que le lendemain on
n'avait pas dit après la deuxième aussi
les bonnes elles se marient là
ce n'est pas sûr d'aller prochaine ouais
bien alors maintenant je vais vous poser
une question à tout là en commençant par
vous violette quelle quelle morale vous
tirer de tout ça maintenant la sortie
c'est à dire après la frêle avis vous
avez eue après après le fait qu'elle
soit devenue une star même si maintenant
il lui reste encore à le prouver elle
commence avec ce bouquin morale vous
tirer de ça si jusque là la manche et
son mauvais pain je dis que là beaucoup
de bons pères manger très bien elle a
mangé le pernois il reste pas un blanc
il y aurait de quoi beaucoup
on espère en tous les cas la nature
ouais et vous il va être la morale que
vous tirez de tout ça là la conclusion
la conclusion c'est que j'espère qu'elle
s'est bien manger de son passé et qu'on
a eu beaucoup de chance warren enfants
quelle morale ou peut être parce que bon
il y avait été soir ce n'est pas évident
elle a gagné le coeur des français
ça c'est clair en étant elle même oui
réseau de pairs ou lui pardonner je
pardonne pas ils sont que j'aimerais le
revoir
peut-être que je perdrais avec des
explications mais pas comme ça et vous
autres marines
non non moi je pardonne rien du tout
même si vous leur envoyez oui
mais même là la force et la maman aussi
je sais de qui tenir
voilà bah écoutez merci donc je rappelle
le titre du livre ces miettes
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux